I'm an honor of Gilmore Girls that we
have we each have an Irish whiskey
decorated by Michael with our face
that's right and you know what I don't
want to be rude and it literally has
whiskey and you love a cup holder yeah
somebody think there's a splash in it
I'm like 90% whiskey and then there's
like a drop it was obvious xn Melissa
you got a heavy hand there okay how many
of y'all are Gilmore girl fans me too
and so now Sookie st. James and I are
about to go head-to-head in a trivia
battle we're calling who's
[Applause]
I'm talking a lot of smack I haven't
seen episode in a while so it's gonna
work I'll ask you ten questions relating
to Gilmore girl or wait Alex this
doesn't work we need a host we need I
can't host and play so who's asking the
questions I am Kelly using my powerful
and very sexy voice God you sound like
Morgan Freeman and I like it for legal
reasons I'm not I am the greatest
Gilmore fan in the universe so it's only
fitting that I ask the questions and be
the judge all right will you also
rerecord my outgoing message all right
you got a girl I'm gonna do I will lead
a series of questions about Gilmore now
the first one to buzz in has five
seconds to answer now if you correct you
get one point but if you're incorrect or
don't answer in time the other person
can steal okay yeah God got a little
sexy all right most points wins and the
winner will receive the most cherished
thing on this earth an Amazon gift card
[Applause]
that's good I am a prime member so I'm
ready you ready you ready to play yes
here's your first question
dinner with the grandparents happened on
which day you gotta go I'm gonna say
Friday I gotta be quicker yes Melissa
one Kelly zero oh thank you for the
reminder thank you here's a question
when Jackson met Suki what was his
occupation
oh he was a he always had the fruit of
the vegetable yeah you know the
vegetables and he come in and he was the
guy to give their dad the vegetables
he's got a brother vegetables here's the
gardener will we expect vegetables no he
had the visions he was the guy that gave
it he was my produce delivery go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not a right answer
I know god I got it wrong she's got to
Polly's going to question me I don't
think let's move on question number
three Luke's diner used to be
[Applause]
once again less Maluku Kelly one is
beating your butt right now alright
here's the next question
how did Rory break her car accident
Jessie in which you scream that my face
was what you know James doesn't like
playing games with me I love an
aggressive gameplay of a tie game and
I'm gonna need to drink myself after
this gives the next question originally
how many children did Jackson want with
Sookie six I'm sorry that's way wrong I
was gonna say four
[Music]
[Applause]
we now have ourselves a game as Kelly
the host of the show now has three
points to Melissa okay three and you've
got it it's not as much now at the
moment which means boy that victory is
gonna be sweet Lorelai named her dog
after whoo no no it's it's no it's the
it's the it's the singer it's the artist
it's a it's a it's a it's the artist a
singer it's like the old dude I can't
remember well the answer you were
looking for was of course Paul Anka yes
we're dumb okay you said I didn't say it
you did and now our next question where
did Jackson propose to Sookie in next to
miss Patty's out on the grass that was
supposed to be at noon and we shot it in
like one o'clock in the morning so we
were just under like crazy klieg lights
trying to make it look like daylight so
we couldn't really look at each other
because it was so bad really I was like
it was so bright we couldn't see each
other we're like oh I retinas no see
acting sounds hard okay all right now we
have a tie game here this is the final
question for the game I feel great about
it and here it is how did Jackson ask
Sookie out on their first big
he you did he didn't ask you out you did
[Applause]
season of Little Big Shots on NBC I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this